Here's some good news.
The president of China
and the United States
just met in San Francisco,
and one of the things they discussed
was pandas.
A few decades ago, China
gave a bunch of pandas to the U.S.
National Zoo
here in Washington, D.C.,
as a sign of friendship and diplomacy.
But recently they took the pandas back
because of the increasing
tensions between these two countries.
But after this meeting
between these two presidents,
Xi Jinping suggested
that they should send the pandas back
as a gesture of their friendship.
I mean, it's kind of bizarre
that diplomatic relations
between the two most powerful
countries is being measured in pandas,
but hey, I'll take it.
If you want to better understand
global politics, follow along for more.